كتله من اللهب اضاءت سماء كردستان العراق
في منتصف الليل جراء المسيرته والصواريخ
الايرانيه
في العراق المجاور للمره الثانيه في اقل
من اسبوع ما انت الى مقتل عنصر من
البشمركه يدعى به ساده وفق الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
تاتي في وقت يعجز فيه النظام
الايرانيات استاذتي ايران مقر حزبين
معارضين اخرين داخل الاقليم وفق وكاله
الانباء العراقيه الرسميه
ادمته بشده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الداعمه للاحتجاجات في ايران الهجمات
العشوائيه وغير القانونيه كهذه تعرض
المدنيين للخطر وتنتهي كل السياده
العراقيه وتقوي امن العراق والشرق الاوسط
واستقرارهما
على المسلحين الاكراد الموجودين في العراق
الذين تعتبرهم مصدر الاحتجاجات التي تهز
البلاد موضوع اكثر من شهرين